y
[Música]
recta final en el camino hacia la casa
blanca cuando faltan sólo horas para las
elecciones presidenciales de eeuu los
candidatos donald trump y joe biden
buscaron adeptos en medio de una
votación anticipada récord con más de 95
millones de sufragios ya emitidos
se vive momentos de tensión en viena
varios tiroteos en el centro de la
capital austriaca resultaron en al menos
dos víctimas mortales y 15 heridos en
las cercanías de una sinagoga y el
casillero sebastián course dijo que se
trató de un ataque terrorista llegan a
su fin los tres días de luto decretados
por el presidente de mexico en honor a
las víctimas del hobbit 19 y en el marco
de las celebraciones del día de muertos
fue una de las conmemoraciones más
atípicas para esta histórica tradición
que esta vez se vivió con los
cementerios cerrados y dentro de los
hogares
[Música]
muy buenas noches bienvenidos a la
noticia de france 24 muchísimas gracias
por acompañarnos como cada día soy
santiago ariztía y comenzamos esta
emisión de noticias en eeuu porque ya
nos encontramos en la recta final en el
camino hacia la casa blanca cuando
faltan pocas horas para las elecciones
presidenciales en este país los
candidatos
donald trump y joe biden siguen buscando
votos en los estados pendulares es decir
aquellos donde no siempre se vota por el
mismo partido político en medio de una
votación anticipada récord con más de 95
millones de sufragios ya emitidos los
candidatos dedicaron su último día de
campaña a los estados que pueden definir
estos comicios un día antes de las
elecciones las encuestas a nivel
nacional ubican a show by the end en
primer lugar aunque con una diferencia
muy cerrada al respecto de donald trump
y para muchos existe la posibilidad de
que estos comicios en eeuu considerados
como los más trascendentales en la
historia reciente de este país derivan
en disturbios o en actos de violencia y
es por eso que durante el día de las
elecciones son muchísimos los edificios
y también los comercios que van a
permanecer cerrados a lo largo de todo
el país desde washington la capital de
eeuu nuestra corresponsal diana
castañeda estuvo dialogando sobre este
tema con comerciantes y conciudadanos
la capital de los eeuu washington 10 y
se está blindando literalmente para el
día de las elecciones el día de mañana
muchos negocios edificios restaurantes
han colocado este tipo de paneles de
madera para protegerse en caso de que se
registren disturbios o estallidos de
violencia eso es lo que estamos haciendo
todos los edificios aquí cerca de la
casa blanca y en aquí en downtown y el
dueño del edificio está pagando para eso
pero si tienes un restaurante chiquito
es una casita cerca tienes que pagar el
shenzhou propio y mañana el día de las
elecciones planea abrir su restaurante
si vamos a ser abierto
por no me importa si hay nieve
elecciones guerras y los empleos
necesitan ganar dinero y la gente
necesita comer entonces vamos a hacer
abierto
todo el tiempo y todos los que podemos
también los bancos como el que se
encuentra mi respaldo han decidido
proteger sus fachadas ante la
posibilidad de saqueos la alcaldesa de
la ciudad miguel dau sobre ha pedido a
los ciudadanos que compren víveres y
alimentos para los próximos dos o tres
días cuál es su opinión yo pienso que sí
hay que prepararse porque uno no sabe lo
que pueda pasar estamos expuestos a todo
entonces este mañana va a ser un día muy
difícil y por ende el miércoles pero
primeramente dios hay que confiar en el
que todo va a salir bien y hay que
prepararse por cualquier cosa si usted
tiene planeado ir a comprar víveres
alimentos o yo ya había comprado y ya
estaba ya lo compre con mi familia ya
estamos preparados por para no trabajar
y para estar estos días más estables
no me ha comprado todavía pero si
podemos ir a comprar porque como la
familia y todo no se sabe cómo se va a
poner esto pues ya mañana
la seguridad también ha sido reforzada
en la ciudad se aumentó el número de
personal del servicio secreto de la
policía metropolitana y estas calles
blindadas reflejan la agitación que se
vivió este año y también la polarización
entre el partido demócrata y republicano
así como el duelo que se verá el día de
mañana entre joe wagner y donaldson en
las urnas en la carrera por la casa
blanca y en otras noticias están
viviendo momentos de tensión en viena la
capital austríaca y es que varios
tiroteos resultaron en al menos dos
víctimas mortales y 15 personas serías
en un barrio de bares y de restaurantes
en las cercanías de una sinagoga las
fuerzas de seguridad del país lanzaron
ya una gran operación y se cree que
serían varias las personas que
dispararon en seis lugares diferentes de
la ciudad pero todos en las
inmediaciones de una calle en la que
está ubicada la sinagoga central de la
ciudad la policía mató a uno de los
atacantes y otro escapó por su parte del
canciller sebastián course dijo que se
trató de un ataque terrorista
es el día más difícil para austria desde
hace muchos años tenemos que enfrentar
un ataque terrorista un hecho que por
suerte no enfrenta vamos a hacer mucho
tiempo tenemos varios heridos varios
muertos
nuestras fuerzas especiales dieron de
baja a un atacante y según la
información que tenemos hay al menos un
sospechoso a la fuga router
y en otras noticias la universidad de
kabul fue hoy el escenario de un ataque
que fue reivindicado por el
autodenominado estado islámico y que
dejó al menos 22 personas muertas y
decenas de heridos
hombres armados irrumpieron en horas de
la mañana en la que es reconocida como
la principal institución educativa de
afganistán asesinando a estudiantes que
se encontraban en las aulas y también
disparando a quienes buscaban escapar
desde la presidencia del país declararon
un día de luto nacional en honor a las
víctimas del que fue el segundo ataque
de este tipo a un centro educativo de
kabul en menos de un mes
y el huracán está toma fuerza y se
espera que siga fortaleciéndose todavía
más mientras se aproxima por el caribe
hacia nicaragua y honduras ésta avanza
con vientos sostenidos de 195 kilómetros
por hora según indicó el centro nacional
de huracanes de estados unidos desde
donde advirtieron además que los efectos
de sus vientos y lluvias en
centroamérica pueden ser marejadas
ciclónicas inundaciones y deslizamientos
de tierra el huracán podría tocar tierra
entre la noche del lunes y la madrugada
del martes cerca de la ciudad
nicaragüense de bilwi
masnoticias de américa latina' este
lunes terminan los tres días de luto que
fueron decretados por el presidente de
méxico andrés manuel lópez obrador en
honor a las víctimas del hobbit 19 pero
en el marco de las celebraciones del día
de muertos hablamos de quizás la fecha
más atípica que se recuerde en la
historia de esta tradición con todos los
cementerios cerrados y bajo la consigna
de que cada uno recuerde a los muertos
suyos desde sus hogares
este año el altar de óscar para sus
muertos está en casa las fotos son de su
esposa con la cuarta cifra de fallecidos
a causa de kobe 19 más alta en el mundo
cerca de los 100 mil decesos algunos
mexicanos como él celebran este día en
la intimidad de su hogar ante el cierre
de una parte de los cementerios
decretado por las autoridades el
falleció mi esposa va a cumplir dos
meses se mañana dos y este y pues me
dejó a mis hijos y pues ahorita y que
más que nada hay que echarle ganas y es
la noche del primero de noviembre al 2
de noviembre la que se considera más
importante en una celebración y en honor
a los difuntos que transcurre a lo largo
de varios días y que comienza el 31 de
octubre este martes no había cementerios
a los que acudir en la capital y tampoco
hay desfiles méxico vive un día de
muertos como quizás nunca antes lo había
hecho usted es nostálgico no oirá
recordar nuestros muertos a las personas
que están en esos espacios y no poder
limpiar sus
estar con ellos conviviendo en este día
es lo que es una nostalgia
en san cristóbal de las casas en el
estado sureño de chiapas si hubo visitas
a los cementerios en este caso son los
pueblos mayas los que festejan el día de
muertos dicen que es una tradición
milenaria a mantener llueva truene con
pandemia o sin pandemia y cada 2 de
noviembre se conmemora el día
internacional para poner fin a la
impunidad de crímenes a periodistas
hablamos de una fecha clave para todos
los comunicadores a lo largo del mundo y
por eso previamente dialogamos con jan
albert hot ser representante en méxico
del comité para la protección de
periodistas y nos daba detalles acerca
de la situación en este país uno de los
más golpeados por la violencia contra
los trabajadores de prensa y esto nos
decía así efectivamente en mexico en
estos momentos se encuentran en una
situación bastante crítica para la
libertad de prensa es el país más
mortífero a nivel mundial para las y los
periodistas tan sólo este año han
asesinado a seis periodistas el más
último asesinato más reciente fue el
viernes de la semana pasada
en ciudad juárez y bueno la realidad es
que en méxico los las y los periodistas
enfrenten una situación múltiple tienen
un problema con debilidad institucional
junto con una ola de violencia por parte
del crimen organizado e impunidad y todo
junto se convierte en un cóctel tóxico
que básicamente se ha convertido en el
país el más peligroso del mundo
regresamos en breve con más noticias y
en en france 24
[Música]